El 8 de agosto del año 2008, el mismo día
que arrancaban los Juegos Olímpicos de Pekín
de ese mismo 2008, el ejército ruso lanzaba
su invasión a gran escala sobre Georgia.
El evento más importante de la década para
China, los juegos olímpicos que iban a culminar
el proceso de plena incorporación del país
comunista a la comunidad internacional, iba
a ser empañado por Vladimir Putin y sus aspiraciones
belicistas.
Por aquel entonces todavía no estaba Xi Jinping
a los mandos de China, sino su predecesor,
Hu Jintao, quien reaccionó discretamente,
pero profundamente irritado con Moscú, por
la fecha escogida para la invasión: el mismo
día que la llama olímpica iluminaría China
por primera vez.)
Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
aunque ha llovido mucho desde entonces, hay
costumbres que nunca cambian.
Como si de una especie de déjà vu se tratara,
Putin tomó la decisión de invadir Ucrania
justo en las fechas en las que China organizaba
otros Juegos Olímpicos, los de invierno de
Pekín 2022.
De hecho, se cree que Xi Jinping le pidió
al líder ruso que dejará su invasión para
después de la clausura. Y sea esto o no cierto,
la cuestión es que solo 4 días después
de la clausura de estos juegos las hordas
de Putin se lanzaron sobre Ucrania.
Desde entonces, la actitud de la República
Popular China ha sido tremendamente ambigua
y errática. Pero sí hay algo que ha quedado
muy claro:
Xi Jinping cada vez está más lejos de sus
predecesores.
Durante todo este tiempo, durante un año
de guerra y a pesar de los terribles crímenes
cometidos por el ejército ruso, el dictador
chino ha permanecido callado… Al menos,
hasta ahora.
Esta imagen seguro que va a tardar en olvidarse.
Sí, finalmente se produjo la imagen que algunos
dudaban que se fuera a producir y que otros
anunciaban como inevitable. Los dictadores
de China y de Rusia, Xi Jinping y Vladimir
Putin, juntos en una cumbre bilateral en el
mismísimo Moscú un año después del inicio
de la guerra.
No ha sido la primera vez que se encuentran
desde el inicio de la invasión, pero sí
ha sido la primera vez que lo hacen al más
alto nivel y en el marco de una cumbre bilateral.
Quizás por eso, muchos han interpretado que
esta visita de Xi a Moscú es todo un espaldarazo
a Putin, una manera de legitimar al mandatario
ruso en la escena internacional y, quizás,
también, blanquear sus operaciones.
Más aún cuando la visita se produjo tan
solo unos pocos días después de que saltaran
noticias como esta.
(Los jueces de la CPI emiten una orden de
arresto para Vladimir Putin por presuntos
crímenes de guerra - The Guardian)
Sin embargo, esto es tan solo la nota a pie
de página. Lo cierto es que la visita de
Xi Jinping a Rusia consiste en algo más que
simples apretones de manos o sonrisas forzadas.
Fue, ante todo, el último intento de Pekín
de convertirse de una vez por todas en la
capital antagónica a Washington. La alternativa
clara al liderazgo occidental.
Ahora bien, ¿Significa todo esto que China
finalmente se pondrá del lado de Rusia? ¿Es
Pekín realmente neutral como ellos defienden
ser? ¿Qué demonios pretenden realmente los
chinos con esta aparente aproximación a Putin?
¿Quién tiene la sartén por el mango en
toda esta historia?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a responder a estas otras preguntas.
Atentos.
T1(EL ‘ORDEN MULTIPOLAR’)
Fijaos en esta llamativa imagen.
En la imagen veis a Wang Yi, director de la
Comisión Central de Asuntos Exteriores del
Partido Comunista Chino, el principal asesor
de política exterior de Xi Jinping, junto
a los representantes de Arabia Saudí y de
Irán.
Dos países que en teoría se odian, ahora
han decido restablecer sus relaciones diplomáticas.
Y lo han hecho gracias a la mediación de
China.
No es muy común ver a los chinos como mediadores
en problemas internacionales, pero parece
que ahora ese es, precisamente, el nuevo que
quiere seguir el régimen chino.
Y el conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania parece
ser su siguiente objetivo.
(A finales del pasado mes de febrero de 2023,
coincidiendo con el primer aniversario de
la guerra, China presentó un plan de doce
puntos para, en teoría, dar una solución
política al conflicto.
En realidad este es una especie de plan lentejas,
o lo tomas o lo dejas. Ni siquiera consultaron
la opinión de Ucrania sobre los doce puntos
presentados.
Tampoco es que sean muy concisos. De hecho,
la mayoría de los puntos incluyen cosas extremadamente
generales como respetar la soberanía de todos
los países, cesar las hostilidades o reducir
los riesgos estratégicos. Lo importante es
que con este documento China ya tenía su
plan de paz.)
En teoría ahora los chinos van a empezar
a trabajar para ver cómo se pueden hacer
realidad esos puntos.
Y eso es seguramente lo que explica noticias
como estás en los medios chinos:
N2(“Los viajes de los líderes europeos
a China destacan el papel de Pekín como "promotor
de la paz" Global Times)
(“Como saben la semana viajaré a la capital
Beijing en viaje oficial y en ese sentido
quiere agradecer al presidente chino Xi Jinping
su invitación [...] Porque creo que es importante
que desde Europa afianzemos una cooperación
entre Europa y China ante retos globales que
trascienden las fronteras”. Pedro Sánchez,
Presidente de España)
Pero, claro, la duda, el gran interrogante
en toda esta historia es… ¿Realmente podemos
considerar a China como un actor neutral entre
Rusia y Ucrania capaz de actuar como país
mediador en este conflicto?
Y es que bueno, ¿Qué queréis que os diga?
Palabras como estas no ayudan:
Y no sé a vosotros, pero, que Xi le diga
a Putin que están impulsando un cambio juntos,
no parece la mejor carta de presentación
para convertirse en el mediador.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque quedarse con
estas imágenes y ya está, sería un análisis
terriblemente simple y desafortunado de toda
esta situación.
Pekín habla de su plan de paz… Pero ¿Y
si a China realmente no le interesa que la
guerra termine pronto?
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien. Esa es
la pregunta.
Y es que veréis, me explico. Inicialmente,
esta guerra ha sido una puñeta para China:
De repente todo el mundo empezó a preocuparse
de la seguridad nacional.
El apoyo occidental a Ucrania superó barreras
que pueden ser consideradas un precedente,
por ejemplo, para Taiwán.
Estados Unidos mejoró mucho su posición
internacional y se permitió el lujo de restringir
la venta de tecnología avanzada a la propia
China.
Y para colmo la ralentización económica
mundial contribuyó a que el crecimiento económico
de China en 2022 se quedará prácticamente
en la mitad del objetivo del gobierno.
Sin embargo, de perdidos al río. Ahora, podemos
encontrar 3 motivos con los que
Y, ojo, porque vamos a encontrar al menos
3 grandes motivos por los que puede que
El primero de ellos tiene que ver con la pasta.
Los beneficios económicos extraordinarios
que China está teniendo por las sanciones
occidentales a Rusia.
¿Queréis un ejemplo concreto de todo esto?
Pues fijaos en este gráfico:
Por supuesto, detrás de las importaciones
chinas está sobre todo la energía.
(La guerra, las sanciones y la desconexión
europea de Rusia le han permitido a China
comprar cantidades récord de gas y petróleo
con fortísimos descuentos, justo además
cuando su economía no atraviesa su mejor
momento. Rusia necesita vender todo lo que
puede, aunque ello suponga vender mucho más
barato.
De esta forma, en los meses de enero y febrero
de 2023, con un incremento de casi el 24%
interanual, Rusia desbancó a Arabia Saudí
como mayor proveedor petrolero de China.)
Por supuesto, Rusia no puede inundar China
de petróleo y gas, básicamente porque a)
carece de la infraestructura y b) al contrario
que, por ejemplo, los alemanes, los chinos
siempre han sido muy recelosos de su seguridad
energética. A comienzos de 2023, la cuota
de Rusia en las compras chinas ya estuvo por
encima del 20%. Así que el margen parece
pequeño.
Aun así, ahora la idea es sustituir las compras
a través de barcos por tuberías. Hablamos,
por ejempl o, de intentar acelerar los plazos
para la construcción del Power Of Siberia
2, un nuevo gasoducto que podría transportar,
a través de más de 2.600 km, hasta 50
mil millones de metros cúbicos de gas, lo
que supondría duplicar la actual capacidad
de exportación de gas ruso a China.
Claro que hay un problema, las estimaciones
chinas pasan por importar 38 mil millones
de metros cúbicos de gas para 2025, mientras
que los rusos aspiran a poder venderles 98
bcm para 2030. Y con el petróleo ocurre tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo. Digamos que existe
una profunda brecha entre lo que China quiere
llegar a comprar y lo que Rusia quiere vender.
Así que, para que los chinos acepten aumentar
aún más su exposición energética a Rusia,
el Kremlin tendrá que comprometer precios
mucho más bajos, dar garantías y pasar por
el aro de lo que diga el Tito Xi.
Porque no olvidéis una cosa: esta no es una
relación entre iguales.
La “relación especial” entre Rusia y
China puede terminar haciendo que el primero
se convierta en una especie de estado vasallo
del segundo.
Y esta es de hecho la segunda gran ventaja
que la guerra puede tener para China: una
influenciea política mucho más grande. Un
nuevo grado de influencia que ellos mismos
han bautizado con nombre y apellido: el orden
multipolar.
(La idea del orden multipolar es juntar a
las esferas de poder de Rusia y de China,
al mundo rusófilo y sinófilo, para crear
un nuevo eje de poder global que sirva de
contrapeso al estadounidense en todos los
campos.
El pequeño detalle es que ahora, con el enorme
debilitamiento que está sufriendo Rusia,
China puede aprovecharse para imponer sus
intereses geopolíticos, económicos y militares
sobre cualquier exigencia rusa.)
¿Algún ejemplo de por dónde podrían ir
los tiros? Pues uno de los posibles escenarios
en los que China podría utilizar a Rusia
para consolidar su poder sería en África.
En una reciente entrega de NotNews os hemos
hablado largo y tendido del particular momento
que está atravesando este continente. Por
cierto, si aún no conocéis NotNews os dejo
el enlace en la descripción.
Pero no solo se trata del campo geoestratégico
cuando hablamos de influencia china. También
está el campo económico. Fijaos.
(Putin le dijo a Xi que Rusia está preparada
para cambiar a yuanes en el comercio exterior
- Yahoo Noticias)
Básicamente, lo que implicaría este cambio
es que Rusia dejaría de comerciar en dólares
con los países de Asia, Latinoamérica y
África, pasándose al Renminbi, que es el
nombre de la moneda de China que comúnmente
se conoce como yuan.
De hecho, en 2022, la participación del yuan
en los pagos de las exportaciones rusas aumentó
del 0,5 al 16 por ciento. Y, por ejemplo,
en febrero de 2023, el yuan superó por primera
vez en la historia al dólar como la moneda
más negociada en la Bolsa de Moscú, con
casi el 40% de las transacciones.
Es lo que muchos ya han denominado como el
Petroyuan… Claro que se han exagerado mucho
sus consecuencias. El yuan no está capacitado
para sustituir al dólar. ¿Por qué? Pues
básicamente porque carece de seguridad jurídica
y porque China mantiene grandes controles
de capitales.
Pero, aun así, este cambio sí que podría
impulsar la influencia de China en Rusia y
en general en toda la región de Asia Central.
Por último, tenemos la cuestión militar.
(Rusia está sufriendo un enorme desgaste
militar, lo que junto a las sanciones están
teniendo dos consecuencias muy claras:
Por un lado, la capacidad militar de Rusia
se ha visto mermada, dejando prácticamente
a China como la única gran potencia militar
en Asia Central. Por otra parte, cuando la
guerra termine y Rusia necesite adquirir nuevos
equipos militares para sustituir sus pérdidas,
si las sanciones no se levantan, es probable
que acudan a la industria militar china para
conseguir hardware o componentes. Y no solo
Rusia. Buena parte de los clientes de este
país podrían poco a poco desplazarse a la
industria china.)
Pues bien, estas serían las 3 vías con las
que China podría aspirar a sacar beneficio
de todo este embrollo. 3 ejes con los que
Xi Jinping parece querer compensar la gran
puñeta que les ha supuesto la guerra.
Y es que es justo aquí cuando llegamos al
gran dilema. Atentos
T2(EL GRAN DILEMA)
Después de lo que os hemos contado en este
vídeo, si tuvierais que responder la pregunta
que os hacíamos al principio sobre si China
es o no realmente neutral con Rusia, ¿Qué
respuesta daríais?
Pues seguramente sea que no, China no tiene
una posición neutral, básicamente porque
Xi Jinping ha encontrado un filón en la guerra
para impulsar su particular agenda de confrontación
con occidente.
Además, no olvidéis que la economía china
está empezando a sufrir un montón de problemas,
así que nada mejor que tener a mano un chivo
expiatorio. Y sabéis, no, la culpa de los
problemas no es nuestra, es de la guerra.
Sin embargo, esta no es toda la historia.
Justo aquí hemos llegado al gran dilema al
que se enfrenta el gobierno chino.
Por un lado, como hemos visto, la guerra puede
tener beneficios para la nueva agenda de Xi
Jinping, pero, por otra parte, también implica
muchos problemas que los medios de comunicación
habitualmente pasan por alto:
Por ejemplo, la guerra está haciendo que
sus vecinos de Asia-Pacífico estén ampliando
su gasto militar y acercándose aún más
a Estados Unidos. Esto puede debilitar estructuralmente
las ambiciones chinas de convertirse en la
potencia hegemónica en Asia -Pacífico.
Al mismo tiempo, también está contribuyendo
a deteriorar aún más las ya de pro si tensas
relaciones económicas, comerciales y políticas
de China con occidente. Que es, justo, lo
que este país no necesita en este momento.
Digamos que la guerra ha hecho que muchos
gobiernos perciban que dictaduras como la
de Putin o la de Xi Jinping no sean de fiar.
Von der Leyen insta a llevar a cabo una política
más dura con China antes de su visita a Pekín
"China ha pasado ya la página de la era de
'reforma y apertura' y se adentra en una nueva
era de seguridad y control".
Nuestra relación está desequilibrada y se
ve cada vez más afectada por las distorsiones
creadas por el sistema de capitalismo estatal
chino.
Así que tenemos que reequilibrar esta relación
Por eso hemos presentado la Ley de Materias
Primas Críticas, para contribuir a diversificar
y asegurar nuestro abastecimiento.
nos centraremos en los acuerdos de libre comercio
donde aún no los tenemos, como con Nueva
Zelanda, Australia, India y nuestros socios
de la ASEAN y Mercosur)
Para colmo, la guerra también está ralentizando
el crecimiento económico mundial, un crecimiento
que China necesita más que nunca para intentar
superar todos los problemas a los que se enfrenta:
hablamos de cosas como el pinchazo de la burbuja
inmobiliaria, la crisis tecnológica, los
problemas bancarios, el hiperendudamiento
de los gobiernos locales, etcétera, etcétera.
Y, claro, de no lograr superar todos estos
desequilibrios, ese nuevo mundo multipolar
con el que tanto sueñan podría tener un
recorrido muy corto.
Amigos, Xi Jinping ha girado intensamente
el timón respecto a sus predecesores… Y
los resultados no han sido particularmente
buenos.
Ahora esta parece ser su última apuesta,
intentar sacar tajada de la guerra que Rusia
ha provocado en Ucrania.
Claro que no está claro que China pueda realmente
lograr algún beneficio de toda esta jugada.
Lo que está claro es que ni es un país neutral
ni tampoco un régimen confiable.
Pero por ahora la pregunta es para ti:
¿Crees que China logrará beneficiarse del
actual contexto? ¿Terminará Rusia convirtiéndose
en una especie de estado vasallo de Pekín?
¿Qué futuro le auguráis a la alianza entre
China y Rusia? ¿Realmente serán capaces
de promover un nuevo orden mundial?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus impresiones y
si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros tanto
a VisualPolitik como a NotNews para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras novedades.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.